so i just finished the live video
talking about the lord of the rings the
rings of power
and it threw up a few really interesting
questions
so let's have a think about it welcome
to sidetrek your sci-fi tv and movie
channel
[Music]
so i wanted to do this really quickly
just to throw up a big question that we
actually asked on the live video
but i'd really love your comments
to really tell me what you think
because let's be honest
the rings of power cost a billion
dollars to make
now
400 million dollars of that went to the
tolkien estate to actually get the
rights to make it in the first place
there's also been a massive amount of
money spent to set the show up
so a lot of that money is actually going
to feed through 50 hours worth of
television
so it's not
as big a number as it sounds
but this is still the most expensive
television show ever made and you can
see on the screen i mean this is
cinema sort of level of special effects
of acting of sets
and everything else so i mean it's a
phenomenally beautiful show nobody can
argue with that
but the question i have to ask is
how does it compare to the house of the
dragon
now the game of thrones prequel was not
something i was particularly excited
about i hate prequels if you're a
regular sidetracker you'll know i hate
prequels i think they're stupid i think
they generally piss on canon and i think
they're a bit of a waste of time a lot
of the time because you kind of already
know what happens
in
the house of the dragon we already know
what happens to targaryens because we've
seen the game of thrones so why bother
doing the prequel
but
i've really enjoyed house of the dragon
i think it's brilliant i think matt
smith is phenomenal and i've really
really enjoyed it so far we're two
episodes in and i'm loving it
i'm not necessarily loving
the rings of power
i like it it's good
it has potential
but
i'm not excited about the next episode
i am excited about the next episode of
house of the dragon
so what does that say about the amount
of money amazon has spent on this show
have they wasted their money because
the game of thrones prequel is costing a
lot less to make
so
get in the comments i'm really really
interested to know what you think about
this
is this a billion quid completely wasted
i'm actually now starting to think that
this show can never be as good as the
price tag suggests
and that is a bit of a problem
house of the dragon is more entertaining
because it's more
grown up
lord of the rings is a 12a
house of the dragon isn't
and we've already seen a lot of that
it's more entertaining it's more
shocking it's more brutal it's more
realistic
is it just more fun to watch
now it's not for everybody and not
everybody likes every show
there are a lot of people that don't
like the lord of the rings prequel just
because it's not their cup of tea
there's a lot of people that don't like
the lord of the rings prequel because
they decided six months ago they weren't
gonna like it and that's just stupid
there are a lot of people that don't
like the prequel of game of thrones and
didn't like game of thrones before that
they thought it was
too many boobs and things
um
but what do you think if
this is a very simple question now to
end the video if i put a gun to your
head and says you could only watch one
of these shows
which one would it be
would you watch the lord of the rings
the rings of power or would you watch
like me the game of thrones
house of the dragon for me all day house
of the dragon it's actually not anything
early a decision it's a very easy choice
so please get in the comments and tell
me which you to choose
as always guys please if you are new to
channel please like subscribe hit that
bell notification share the video
wherever the hell you like also really
consider hitting the join button that
really helps the channel out and shows
your support
as always please stay safe and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you